I wanted I know that we always have
pleasantries right here but I wanted to
I love you and I also am I hate you a
lot because of your new travel thing oh
the travel shows what do you hate about
the travel that you get to go do them
yeah and somehow you figured out that
you can come here have a great audience
and have a great show oh I guess I want
to go do a show in Italy so I'm just
gonna go - we usually went to Italy
about a week ago
I saw the instagrams everywhere yeah but
you're you're having a go it's it really
pisses me off
yeah because it was really a who takes
like your wife with you god no no that
marriage is a sham look I've got a ring
why wouldn't you take no I would love to
actually in all seriousness I love going
to Italy and I would love to take my
wife this was a work trip so we were up
early in the war but we had to get up
early in Italy oh did you go have to
have like an espresso and a payaso
yes you know in a Cornetto and you and
you met you had to have it like a nice
lunch yeah and then you walked around
Italy yeah and then you had a really
great dinner yeah did you did you drink
wonderful Italian wine I don't like to
have wine I think all kind of alcohol is
bad for you and no one should have it
no one believes yeah and of course I had
wine yes I bought a helmet and I put the
wine a bottle on each side of my head
and there was a straw going in each side
and will you come home doesn't your wife
go how was Italy yeah you were like oh
yeah was so hard yeah I had I started
with red wine one night and then I
switched to white yeah and then went
back to red okay we get it okay you're
very bitter about this we do work very
hard yes there was some drinking of wine
but there was a lot of work as well and
my wife does not like to go on those
work trips doesn't like it she doesn't
like to see work Conan because he's a
prick okay
all right guys stand out I get out why
did you have to pick at the scab no one
wanted to know that now they know hey
would you if someone said to you hey I
have to go work in Italy how would you
feel about it let's say together you
call me
okay yes you're right I would love to go
work with you sometime I don't know I in
Hawaii that would be fun or Paris
explore the culture of Hawaii yeah
together
you